這是第 12 集
題目是：對比式解釋
用幾何跟拓樸來看
講者 Marina Meila 做流形學習
研究資料在高維空間裡實際攤成什麼形狀
反事實解釋這題
她寫過一篇整理 350 篇論文的綜述
這場她把 counterfactual 這個詞讓給因果那一派
自己的版本叫 contrastive
對比式解釋
先把這集要問的問題講清楚
反事實解釋的標準定義
照她投影片上那一頁
給一筆有標籤的資料集 D
每筆標 0 或 1
一個被判成 0 的查詢點 x0
還有一個距離函數 d
輸出 x1
就是所有標 1 的點裡面
離 x0 最近的那一筆
白話講：模型拒絕了你
就找一個跟你最像
但被接受的人給你看
那一頁還列了幾條額外要求
x1 要可信
不能是資料裡根本長不出來的點
從 x0 到 x1 的路徑要短
要可信
x1 要穩定
而且最好用使用者自己的概念來講
幾百種方法都在比誰找的 x1 比較好
Meila 問的不是這個
她把每一個被拒絕的 x0 對到自己的 x1
問這個對應本身：第一
是不是每個 x0 都真的有一個 x1
第二，x0 挪一點點
x1 是跟著挪一點點
還是跳到別的地方去
答案分三段：把 f 當成地形
解釋就是從你的位置往上爬到門檻的那條路
地形裡沒有坡度為零的點，兩題都是有
這是她的定理
一有臨界點或有洞
就有人爬到一半停住、有人的解釋跳開
這是她的反例
最後她換成用概念來爬同一座山
算出兩條路終點差多少
做反事實解釋的方法有幾百種
大多是一套程序，這是一個例子
給我一個相似、但輸出不同的東西
而我感興趣的是
如果把所有可能的輸入
對到所有可能的輸出
那會是什麼樣的函數？
這就是這場演講的目標
用地形圖來想
f 是高度，也就是被接受的機率
她說的 level set
就是等高線
你站在下面那條 τ0 上
門檻是上面那條 τ
標準做法是找離你最近的一點
她改成走路：從你的位置出發
每一步都走最陡的上坡
這條路叫梯度流，永遠跟等高線垂直
走到 τ 那條線停下來的地方
就是你的解釋 x1
下面那條線上每一點都這樣走一遍
就是她說的那個對應，她寫成 Φ
她接著把舞台畫出來，右邊這張就是
上面那條線是 M^τ，門檻
下面那條是 M^τ0，所有起點
左邊綠色的線是密度剛好等於門檻的地方
她叫這個門檻 ρ
再過去的點太不可信，不算
中間那個綠圈是資料裡的一塊空洞
一樣不可信
右邊藍色的線是資料本來的邊界
兩條綠的加一條藍的，她合稱垂直邊界
記成 B
後面所有的圖都畫在這一塊裡面
坡度為零的地方有三種：山頂、谷底
還有兩座山中間的山口，叫鞍點
Morse 函數多要求一件事
這些點都要乾脆，不能是一整片平台
Hessian 沒有零特徵值講的就是這個
對解釋來說，臨界點是陷阱
往上爬的路一走進去
最陡的上坡就沒有方向了，路停在那裡
永遠到不了門檻
那我們有一個很好用的定理，它說
這是它的圖
如果這張圖沒有洞，不對
如果這張圖裡 f 沒有臨界點
那下面那層跟上面那層就是微分同胚
順著流，每一個輸入 x0 都有一個解釋 x1
每個都不一樣，這個對應是可逆的
性質非常非常好
這是用 Morse 理論的一個理由：有這個好結果
但我其實還沒證明我們真的有 Morse 函數
我們希望有，理由就是這個
在講怎樣才算 Morse 函數之前
這也區分了靠近決策邊界的解釋
跟所有地方的解釋
因為在邊界附近，如果這裡沒有臨界點
就會有一塊鄰域完全沒有臨界點
這件好事就會發生
所以我們可以說：這就是我的對比式解釋
永遠存在一塊鄰域，裡面的對比式解釋都很好
其他地方就別問我了
把定理拆開看
條件跟結論都在這一頁上
條件一：兩條等高線上本身沒有臨界點
條件二
f 的梯度在垂直邊界上不跟邊界垂直
白話就是流線不從側邊穿出去
這兩條成立
這一塊在拓樸裡叫 cobordism
條件三：整塊裡面都沒有臨界點
結論
下面那條 M^τ0 跟上面那條 M^τ 微分同胚
而且這個同胚就是梯度流本身
翻成人話：每個起點都有解釋
不同的人解釋一定不同，起點連續動
解釋也連續動
為什麼成立：沒有臨界點
流線沒有地方可以停
只能從下面一路走到上面
流線彼此不交叉，所以一對一
微分方程的解對起點連續，所以連續
她做的是把這個現成的定理接到反事實解釋上
引用的是頁上標 BNR12 那篇帶邊界的 Morse 理論
她沒做的她自己講了
還沒證明真實的 f 沒有臨界點
只保證決策邊界附近有一圈成立
其他地方別問她
這個例子裡，流線從垂直邊界穿出去
穿過洞，又從別的地方進來
這種情況下，定理就不成立
很明顯，τ0 那條等高線上有些點拿不到解釋
她的修法只動邊界
沿垂直邊界留一圈寬度 ε 的鄰域
只在這一圈裡改 f
讓梯度貼著邊界走，不再穿出去
其他地方的 f 不動
原本的臨界點也都還在
代價是多一個參數 ε
邊界那一圈的解釋是改過的 f 給的
修完就只剩臨界點，就是這張圖
最下面那條線是起點 τ0
淺藍色箭頭是往上爬的路
最上面那條線是門檻 τ
紅點是臨界點
拿右上角這個缺口來看
從缺口左邊一點點出發的人
停在缺口的左岸
起點往右挪一點點，終點就跳到右岸
中間隔了一整個缺口
這就是 Φ 不連續
正對缺口底部出發的那個人
走進紅點就停住，什麼解釋都拿不到
所以這張圖證明的是：只要有臨界點
就有人沒有解釋，而且 Φ 不連續
她沒給的是哪些起點會出事
那一塊有多大，這取決於 f 的拓樸
那為什麼這很重要？
這只是一個很小很小的洞
一部分是連續性的問題，一部分是別的
如果一個定義域有任何一種洞
就沒辦法只用一張座標圖來描述它
沒辦法用單一一張座標，把它攤平到實數上
這大概是今天最該帶回家的一件事
其實這也是最重要的挑戰
我不假裝我已經解決了
基本上，就算只有一個點的洞
就沒辦法用一張全域的地圖把它看成實數線
所以得替解釋所在的空間想另一種拓樸
某種看起來像有洞的定義域
這就是我想傳達的訊息
就算在這個極限裡
只要問解釋穩不穩定
拓樸就不能忽略，拓樸就是答案
函數的拓樸描述
會告訴我們手上這個解釋有什麼性質
後半場她把同一條上坡路換成用概念來走
我們壓成一段
概念是使用者的語言，像腫瘤大小
血流速度
每個概念 c 都是 x 的函數
她不逼近 f 本身
只逼近 f 的梯度：在每一點上
f 最陡的那支箭頭
用幾個概念的箭頭加權湊出來
權重 β 每個點都不一樣
誤差每一點都不超過 δ
接著兩條路從同一個起點出發
一條照真的梯度走，一條照湊的走
她的上界
兩個終點的距離不超過 δ 除以 L
乘上 e 的 L 倍 τ 減 τ0 次方再減一
L 是 f 二階導數的上界
白話：誤差隨要爬的高度指數放大
她沒做的三件
概念不夠用的情況沒分析
概念到 f 的對應她假設全域成立
流形有洞還要多一個全域條件
她說那一條目前什麼都說不出來
還有一件很棒的事，我想特別強調
數學其實跟我們的直覺對得上
基本上，如果軌跡比較長，起點 τ0 比較低
想要一樣準，δ 就要變小
有一條很簡單的式子
代入 ε 就會看到，δ 必須越來越小
因為要補的差距更大，理所當然
局部的逼近要更精準
而局部逼近要更精準
就可能需要越來越多概念
所以這自動告訴我，如果我想
向一個差得更遠的人解釋
我需要一個更長、更複雜的解釋
這一點都不意外
只是確認了我們的方向可能是對的
沒有做出違反直覺的東西
整場收成一句
反事實解釋是一個對應 Φ
它存不存在、連不連續
由 f 的地形決定
資料再多也改不了
她做到的：把解釋寫成梯度流
證明沒有臨界點時人人有解釋而且連續
畫出有臨界點時誰拿不到、哪裡會跳
還有概念版的誤差上界
她沒做到的，她的結論頁自己列了
解釋應該附上一個複雜度
一部分是路徑長度，一部分是拓樸
兩個怎麼合起來是開放問題
還有整場都在理想世界裡：f、流形
密度全當成已知，沒有資料
也沒有實驗
下一場是 Columbia 大學的 Elias Bareinboim
Judea Pearl 的學生
因果這一派
Meila 把反事實這個詞讓給了因果
Bareinboim 要講的就是
AI 要會做因果推理
才講得出真正的解釋
他的第一個例子是問生圖模型
貓把花瓶推下桌會怎樣
模型自己把墊子拿掉，再讓花瓶摔碎
十歲小孩都看得出不對
最強的模型卻看不出來
原影片連結在說明欄，整場 53 分鐘，有興趣可以去聽更多。